This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. The Old Testament tells the story of King Saul, a ruler who was frequently gripped by waves of anguish and despair. When Saul was afflicted by such torments, his advisors didn't always call for a physician or a priest. Instead, they summoned a young shepherd named David, known for his skill at playing the liar. As the music began to play, King Saul's mind would settle and his mood would lift.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。《旧约》讲述了扫罗王的故事，这位统治者经常被痛苦和绝望的浪潮所困扰。当扫罗受到这种折磨时，他的顾问并不总是求助于医生或牧师。相反，他们会召来一位名叫大卫的年轻牧羊人，他以弹奏里拉琴的技艺而闻名。当音乐响起时，扫罗王的心绪就会平静下来，心情也会随之好转。
For centuries, stories like this have been treated as legend, poetic, symbolic, even mystical. But do they point to something real? Today, a growing body of scientific research suggests that music, painting, dance, and storytelling, do far more than entertain us. They calm our nervous systems, reshape our emotions, and even influence our physical health. This week on Hidden Brain,
几个世纪以来，这类故事一直被视为传说、诗歌、象征，甚至是神秘主义。但它们是否指向了某种真实的东西？如今，越来越多的科学研究表明，音乐、绘画、舞蹈和讲故事的作用远不止娱乐我们。它们能平复我们的神经系统，重塑我们的情绪，甚至影响我们的身体健康。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，
and in a companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, why the arts are no luxury, but rather a vital form of medicine for the mind. Think about the last time a piece of music stopped you in your tracks, or a novel kept you up late into the night, or a painting made you feel something you couldn't quite put into words. Why do these experiences feel so powerful? For a long time, scientists didn't have a clear answer.
以及在《隐藏的大脑 Plus》的配套故事中，我们将探讨为什么艺术不是奢侈品，而是心灵的一剂良药。回想一下，上一次有一段音乐让你驻足，或者一本小说让你深夜难眠，又或者一幅画让你产生了一种无法用言语表达的感觉，是在什么时候？为什么这些体验感觉如此强大？很长一段时间以来，科学家们都没有明确的答案。
The arts seemed too subjective, too personal, to study in any systematic way. But that's starting to change. At University College London, Psychobiologist Daisy Fancourt has found that these moments are not just meaningful, they're measurable, and they can play a crucial role in our emotional and psychological well-being. Daisy Fancourt, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's lovely to be with you. Daisy, as a young woman, you were very involved in music, singing and playing the piano. What did you notice about the emotional and psychological effects that music and the arts had on you and your friends?
艺术似乎太主观、太个人化，无法以任何系统的方式进行研究。但这种情况正在开始改变。在伦敦大学学院，心理生物学家黛西·范考特发现，这些时刻不仅有意义，而且是可以衡量的，它们可以在我们的情感和心理健康中发挥至关重要的作用。黛西·范考特，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴能和你在一起。黛西，作为一名年轻女性，你非常热衷于音乐，唱歌和弹钢琴。你注意到音乐和艺术对你和你朋友的情感和心理产生了什么影响？
I feel really lucky because I was born into a family of professional musicians, so the arts were just so much a part of my day-to-day upbringing. I don't think I really reflected on what a privilege that is to have that kind of exposure at such a young age. I mean, I remember so clearly that if ever I felt stressed or worried about anything as a teenager, I used to go and play the piano just sort of instinctively, and I knew that was something that would help me. And I certainly have noticed that a lot of the relationships, the friendships that I built early on, they came through playing music with friends being in orchestras or bands or being involved in musical theatre. So I think it was a lot more fundamental and foundational to me than I necessarily appreciated at that young age.
我觉得自己很幸运，因为我出生在一个专业音乐家家庭，所以艺术是我日常成长中非常重要的一部分。我不认为我当时真正反思过在如此年轻的时候拥有这种接触机会是一种多么大的特权。我的意思是，我清楚地记得，如果我在青少年时期感到压力或担忧，我习惯于本能地去弹钢琴，我知道那是有助于我的事情。我当然也注意到，我早期建立的许多关系和友谊，都是通过和朋友一起演奏音乐、参加管弦乐队或乐队，或者参与音乐剧而建立的。所以我认为，这对我来说比我在那个年轻的时候所意识到的要基础和根本得多。
I understand, Daisy, that while you were in college, you began working in a pediatric hospital. Tell me about this work, where it was and what you did. It was an incredible program that was open to students at Oxford University where I was studying. And alongside your studies, you could train to go and deliver arts programs in hospitals. And it was something I just jumped at immediately because I was still fascinated by science and research.
黛西，我了解到你在大学期间开始在一家儿科医院工作。跟我说说这份工作，它在哪里，你做了什么？这是一个非常棒的项目，向我在牛津大学学习时的学生开放。在学习之余，你可以接受培训，去医院开展艺术项目。我立刻就抓住了这个机会，因为我仍然对科学和研究着迷。
medicine and keen to find a way to blend the two. So we received training and then worked in pediatric hospital wards doing singing workshops with the children. And I was just completely blown away by the impact that I saw the singing having. I kind of expected it to be a nice bit of entertainment. But actually I was seeing directly that singing with children who were really anxious and crying and distressed would stop them crying and would actually completely calm them down. And I saw these amazing interactions between patients and their siblings that actually music was providing this form of emotional
医学，并且渴望找到一种将两者结合的方法。所以我们接受了培训，然后在儿科病房工作，和孩子们一起做歌唱工作坊。我完全被我所看到的歌唱带来的影响所震撼了。我原以为这只是一种不错的娱乐活动。但实际上，我直接看到，与那些非常焦虑、哭泣和痛苦的孩子一起唱歌，会让他们停止哭泣，并能让他们完全平静下来。我看到了病人和他们的兄弟姐妹之间那些令人惊叹的互动，音乐实际上为他们提供了这种情感
and social connection for them, even in this very challenging and often inhumane kind of environments of the hospital. So I was actually able to witness the benefits I hadn't really appreciated that music could have. I understand that on one occasion you observed a premature baby in the hospital who was crying inconsolably and refusing to eat.
和社交联系，即使是在医院这种非常具有挑战性且往往不近人情的环境中。所以我实际上能够亲眼见证我之前并没有真正意识到音乐所能带来的好处。我了解到，有一次你在医院观察到一个早产儿，他哭闹不止，拒绝进食。
Tell me that story. We were working in NICUS, the neonatal intensive care units, with some of the parents and actually trying to help the mothers sing with their babies. And I remember this one child who was just crying and crying, and the mother was really struggling, and you could see it was really impacting her psychologically as well. But as soon as we started singing this lullaby and she started singing along with her baby as well, the baby's behaviour just completely changed. And within a couple of minutes, it was suddenly feeding again.
给我讲讲那个故事。我们当时在新生儿重症监护室（NICU）与一些父母一起工作，实际上是在尝试帮助母亲与她们的婴儿一起唱歌。我记得有一个孩子一直在哭，母亲非常挣扎，你可以看出这对她的心理也产生了很大的影响。但当我们开始唱这首摇篮曲，她也开始跟着为她的孩子唱歌时，婴儿的行为完全改变了。几分钟之内，它突然又开始进食了。
I'm assuming that part of this might have also been that singing was kind of, the mom down, and perhaps that was also sending a signal to her child. Absolutely, and this is something that we actually saw so many times across different wards, that often the parents were the ones who were the most anxious and really actually struggling the most with the situations they were in, and actually giving them a way that they could engage and play and respond with their children through singing was something that was supporting that whole family unit together. Another time you saw a child being treated for burns, he was in severe pain.
我假设这其中一部分原因可能是唱歌让妈妈平静了下来，也许这也向她的孩子传递了一个信号。绝对是这样，这是我们在不同病房多次看到的情况，通常父母才是最焦虑、在他们所处的环境中挣扎最厉害的人，而给他们一种可以通过唱歌与孩子互动、玩耍和回应的方式，是支持整个家庭单元的事情。还有一次，你看到一个孩子正在接受烧伤治疗，他处于剧痛之中。
What did you observe, Daisy? Well, after I finished college, I actually got a full-time job working in our National Health Service. So working in hospitals, designing new arts programs. And one of the wards we worked on was in the emergency departments. And I remember there was a little boy who'd come in who'd had really terrible burns. And there was a delay in managing to get morphine to him. And he was calling out for pain relief. But actually, there was a theatre group that we had in the hospital.
黛西，你观察到了什么？嗯，大学毕业后，我实际上在我们的国家医疗服务体系（NHS）找到了一份全职工作。所以是在医院工作，设计新的艺术项目。我们工作的其中一个病房是在急诊科。我记得有一个小男孩进来，他受了非常严重的烧伤。在他获得吗啡的过程中出现了延误。他一直在呼喊着要求止痛。但实际上，我们医院里有一个剧团。
And they started doing this performance for him in the emergency department. And again, it was just this complete change. in his behaviour. He suddenly wasn't asking for pain relief. He was smiling and laughing along with what they were doing. And you could see that that distraction that had provided had been sufficient for him no longer to feel out of control in that pain situation.
他们开始在急诊科为他表演。同样，他的行为发生了彻底的改变。他突然不再要求止痛了。他随着他们的表演微笑着、大笑着。你可以看出，那种分散注意力的效果已经足够让他不再感到在那种疼痛的情况下失去控制。
And was this theatrical production? Was it aimed at children? Was it aimed at his age group? Yes, it was. It was from a wonderful group called Chicken Shed who specialised in how you could engage young people with the arts. And we brought them into the hospital. They'd specialized in working in disabilities.
这个戏剧作品是针对儿童的吗？是针对他的年龄段的吗？是的，确实如此。它来自一个很棒的团体，叫“鸡舍”（Chicken Shed），他们专门研究如何让年轻人参与艺术。我们把他们带进了医院。他们专门从事残疾人工作。
art, but we brought them in and said, well, can we adapt this and develop programs that would be really targeting the children who are in the hospital? And they delivered some amazing programs across our pediatric wards. So even as you were seeing the effects that the arts were having on patients, you were also noticing that among some of your colleagues, doctors and administrators, they saw this as a form of entertainment, not as a form of therapy. Can you talk about this disconnect that you've experienced, Daisy? Well, it was a sort of a situation. where if people didn't know what it was and you started describing it, it was sort of described as, oh, yeah, the hospital entertainment program. But actually I noticed that as soon as we started
艺术，但我们把他们带进来，说，好吧，我们能调整一下并开发一些真正针对医院里孩子的项目吗？他们在我们的儿科病房开展了一些很棒的项目。所以，即使你在观察艺术对病人产生的影响，你也注意到在你的同事、医生和行政人员中，他们把这视为一种娱乐，而不是一种治疗。你能谈谈你所经历的这种脱节吗？嗯，这是一种情况。
working closely with clinicians on their wards, they actually really started to get it. They started to see this impact. Like we brought music onto the dementia wards. And immediately when we started playing these songs, there were these patients who couldn't remember their relatives, but were suddenly singing along word perfect. And you could see the clinicians suddenly looking up and noticing. and then we were having these great conversations where we were saying, well, how can we use this? How can we use this with the patients to support them whilst they're in hospital? So I was seeing these moments-to-moment transitions in how the arts were being perceived
如果人们不知道它是什么，而你开始描述它时，它会被描述为，“哦，是的，医院娱乐项目。”但实际上我注意到，一旦我们开始与临床医生在他们的病房密切合作，他们实际上真的开始理解了。他们开始看到这种影响。比如我们将音乐引入痴呆症病房。当我们开始播放这些歌曲时，立即就有一些病人，他们记不住自己的亲人，但突然能一字不差地跟着唱。你可以看到临床医生突然抬头注意到了。然后我们进行了很好的对话，我们说，好吧，我们如何利用这一点？我们如何利用这一点来支持病人在住院期间的情况？所以我看到了艺术被感知方式的瞬间转变
by the clinical staff as we started working more closely with them. But it was still at a stage where we didn't fully have the evidence to sort of say, well, that's because of these scientific studies. We were seeing the impact, but not always having those scientific papers to fall back on to explain it. So it really highlighted for me this gap in terms of scientific research in being able to make that case rather than having to demonstrate it physically all the time. Daisy had seen that engagement with the arts was healing people and making them whole. When we come back, we follow Daisy as she becomes a researcher.
随着我们开始与临床工作人员更密切地合作，他们对艺术的看法也发生了变化。但当时我们还没有足够的证据来断言，这是因为这些科学研究。我们看到了影响，但并不总是有那些科学论文作为后盾来解释它。所以这对我来说确实突显了科学研究方面的差距，即能够提出这种论点，而不是一直不得不从物理上展示它。黛西已经看到，参与艺术正在治愈人们，使他们变得完整。当我们回来时，我们将跟随黛西，看她如何成为一名研究人员。
She discovers why the arts have such striking effects and how to integrate them into the practice of medicine. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. After seeing firsthand the benefits of the arts in her own life and in the lives of her patients, Daisy Fancourt became a researcher. She started to generate hard scientific evidence for the benefits of the arts on our health. Over the past couple of decades, she and others have identified distinct ways in which the arts affect our bodies and our minds.
她发现了为什么艺术会有如此显著的效果，以及如何将它们融入医学实践中。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在亲眼目睹了艺术在自己生活和病人生活中的益处后，黛西·范考特成为了一名研究人员。她开始为艺术对我们健康的益处产生确凿的科学证据。在过去的几十年里，她和其他人已经确定了艺术影响我们身体和心灵的不同方式。
Daisy, you say that engaging with the arts can elevate our mood and ease. increase our sense of well-being, not just in the moment, but over time. How is this happening? And do we understand the brain mechanisms behind this? It's actually one of the things people report the most when you ask them how they feel when they engage in the arts. They'll often say they feel happier. And we actually are really starting to understand more about the neuroscience of why this is. Because when we engage in the arts, we are essentially activating pleasure centres in the brain and reward networks like the dopaminergic system, which leads to the release of neurotransmitters like dopamine, which are involved in those
黛西，你说参与艺术可以提升我们的情绪，缓解压力。增加我们的幸福感，不仅是在当下，而且随着时间的推移。这是怎么发生的？我们了解这背后的脑机制吗？当你问人们参与艺术时的感受时，这实际上是人们报告最多的事情之一。他们通常会说他们感到更快乐。我们实际上真的开始更多地了解这背后的神经科学。因为当我们参与艺术时，我们本质上是在激活大脑中的快乐中心和奖励网络，比如多巴胺能系统，这会导致多巴胺等神经递质的释放，这些神经递质参与了那些
feelings of happiness, of pleasure. And actually, we used to think that we just got these dopamine releases at the kind of peak moments of arts experiences, like if you're listening to a song, and that chorus comes back and you have that kind of yes moments. But we also now know that you get those in anticipation of those moments. It's the build-up to the return of that chorus. Or if you're reading a story, it's those moments when you're about to find out who the murderer is in a big detective novel, for example. And actually, that's why the arts are so effective at giving us these dopamine releases, because arts experiences are constantly about tension and resolution and anticipating what
幸福感、愉悦感。实际上，我们过去认为我们只是在艺术体验的巅峰时刻获得这些多巴胺释放，比如如果你正在听一首歌，副歌部分回来，你会有那种“就是这样”的时刻。但我们现在也知道，你在期待这些时刻时也会得到这些释放。这是副歌回归前的铺垫。或者如果你正在读一个故事，那是当你即将发现侦探小说中的凶手是谁时的那些时刻，例如。实际上，这就是为什么艺术在给我们提供这些多巴胺释放方面如此有效，因为艺术体验总是关于紧张和解决，以及期待可能发生的事情，看看我们是否正确，或者我们的期望是否受挫。所以本质上，当我们参与艺术时，我们是在给大脑提供这些重复剂量的多巴胺。这有助于我们在当下感到更快乐。但随着时间的推移，我们也看到，我们参与得越规律，我们的幸福水平就越高，我们的生活满意度就越高。特别是如果我们也参与到做艺术和创作艺术中，它可以影响我们幸福感的许多其他方面，比如我们的自尊、我们的意义感、目的感和生活中的自主权。
might happen and seeing if we're right or having our expectations thwart it. So essentially, when we engage in the arts, we are giving our brains these repeated doses of dopamine. And that helps us to feel happier in the moment. But also over time, we see that the more regularly engaged we are, the higher the levels of our happiness that we have, the higher our life satisfaction. And particularly if we're getting involved in doing and making arts as well, it can affect so many other aspects of our well-being, like our self-esteem, our sense of meaning and purpose and autonomy in our lives.
现在，艺术唤起了各种不同的情绪，所以我们可能会，你知道，看一部恐怖电影感到害怕，或者我们可能会听重金属音乐感到兴奋。这些体验怎么也能产生快乐和平静的感觉，而在某些方面，这些体验本身似乎与快乐和平静背道而驰？这是真的。这感觉像是一个悖论，不是吗？即你可以看一部恐怖电影或读一本非常悲伤的书，但不知何故它仍然对你的幸福有益。原因在于，当我们参与艺术时，例如悲伤、恐怖或令人震惊的艺术体验，我们实际上同时体验到了积极和消极的情绪。
Now, the arts evoke all kinds of different emotions, so we might, you know, watch a horror movie and feel scared, or we might listen to heavy metal and feel pumped up. How is it that these experiences can also produce feelings of happiness and peace when, in some ways the experiences themselves might seem antithetical to happiness and peace. It's true. It feels like a paradox, doesn't it, that the idea you could watch a horror movie or read a really sad book, but somehow it's still good for your well-being. And the reason for this is that when we engage in arts in, for example, sad or scary or shocking arts experiences, we actually experience positive and negative emotions simultaneously.
所以如果你在现实生活中经历那些悲伤、恐怖或令人震惊的事件，那可能只会是深深的创伤。但因为我们知道这是艺术，我们的大脑对待它的方式有点不同。所以我们在我们和那种艺术体验之间有一点审美距离。这种距离意味着我们体验到了那些情绪，但我们不必对它们做出反应。我们不必像改变生活中的恐怖经历那样去改变它。我们不必试图阻止那种恐惧。所以实际上我们有机会去思考它。这意味着我们的大脑有机会排练它们可能如何调节自己的情绪，或者思考我们可能如何在现实世界中做出反应。
So if you experience those sad, scary or shocking events in real life, it would just be probably deeply traumatic. But because we know it's art, our brain treats us a little bit differently. So we've got a little bit of an aesthetic distance between us and that art experience. And that distance means that we experience those emotions, but we don't have to respond to them. We don't have to change like the scary experience in our lives. We've not got to try and stop that fear. So actually we get to contemplate it. That means our brains get to rehearse how they might regulate their emotions or think about how we might respond in the real world.
这实际上是我们大脑喜欢做的事情。而且这对我们来说也确实非常好，因为我们的大脑是预测机器。所以当我们参与艺术时，我们实际上是在帮助自己接触新的情况，这可以帮助我们在现实生活中遇到复杂体验时进行导航。而且，即使是像在我们感到悲伤时听悲伤的歌曲，它也能给我们一种真实的心理连接感，一种其他人可能经历过类似情绪的感觉，这也可以在心理上支持我们。也许这就是为什么当人们非常难过时，
And that's actually something our brains love to do. And it's actually really good for us as well because our brains are prediction machines. So when we engage in the arts, we're actually helping to expose ourselves to new situations that can help us navigate complex experiences when they come up in our real lives. And also that those experiences, even like listening to sad songs when we're feeling sad, it can give us a feeling of kind of authentic emotional connection, the feeling that other people might have experienced similar emotions, and that can also support us psychologically. And perhaps this is why when people are really upset,
有时他们会去听悲伤的歌曲，这看起来很矛盾，因为你会认为人们会想听快乐的歌曲，但我们经常是在寻找与我们内在情绪气压计相匹配的音乐。完全正确。实际上，有时正是通过聆听那些歌词和歌曲或那些旋律，我们才能开始更好地理解我们自己的情绪，这意味着我们随后可以处理它们，并能够更好地应对它们。
sometimes they reach for sad songs, which would seem paradoxical, because you would think that people would want to listen to songs that are happy songs, but very often we are looking for music that matches our internal emotional barometers. Exactly. And actually sometimes it's through listening to, those lyrics and songs or those melodies that we can start to understand our own emotions better, and that means we can then process them and be able to cope with them better, too.
我们最近在《隐藏的大脑》中有一位嘉宾，科尔顿·斯克里夫纳，他谈到了观看恐怖电影或恐怖体验的影响，他正在研究这些对我们心灵的影响。但当你现在说话时，我意识到在某些方面，当我们观看关于鲨鱼或某种怪物的恐怖电影时，存在一种平行关系，在某些方面它是一种暴露疗法。确实如此。你在年幼的孩子身上看得最清楚，他们可能想一遍又一遍地读鬼故事
We had a guest on Hidden Brain recently, Colton Skriffner, who talked about the effects of watching horror movies or scary experiences, and he was studying the effects that these have on our minds. But as you're talking right now, I'm realizing that in some ways there's a parallel when we watch a scary movie about a shark or a monster of some kind, in some ways It's a form of exposure therapy. It is. You see this most clearly with young children who might want to read a ghost story over and over again
因为他们的大脑在练习，体验那种恐惧，管理那种恐惧，能够合理化它。我们经常被那些恐怖的体验所吸引。但这里有一种警告，就是有些人像我一样讨厌恐怖电影。这是因为实际上我们忘记了它是艺术。当我看恐怖电影时，
because their brains are practicing, having that fear, managing that fear, being able to rationalise it. And we're often really drawn to those scary experiences. But there is a kind of caveat here, which is some people like me hate scary films. And that's because actually we're forgetting that it is art. When I watch a scary movie,
我被深深地吸引进去，我有点认为它是现实生活。因此，我失去了那种距离，我只是感到害怕。所以这里确实有一种警告，即我们必须为了艺术而欣赏这些体验。同样的原因，为什么有时如果我们感到悲伤时听了很多悲伤的歌曲，我们又会陷得太深，实际上发现它并没有以正确的方式支持我们。谈谈艺术在帮助我们调节情绪方面的作用，斯泰西。当我们参与艺术时，它实际上可以给我们的大脑提供一种管理情绪的工具包，所以有时可能是如果我们正在绘画、跳舞、唱歌或打鼓
I get so drawn into it, I kind of think it's real life. And therefore, I lose that distance and I just get scared. So that is a kind of caveat here is that we have to be appreciating those experiences for art. And it's the same way why sometimes if we've listened to a lot of really sad songs when we're feeling sad, again, we can get drawn in just a little bit too much and actually find that it's not supporting us in the right way. Talk about the role of the arts in helping us to regulate our emotion, Stacey. when we engage in the arts it can actually give our brain a kind of toolkit of ways of managing our emotions so some of the time it can be that if we are painting or dancing or singing or drumming
那么我们实际上是在宣泄性地摆脱我们的情绪，我们可能是在发泄它们，例如如果我们感到愤怒，或者通过我们的艺术表达那些情绪，但也有其他时候，实际上将我们自己与生活中的情绪拉开距离真的会对我们有帮助。如果我们正在做艺术，它可以给我们一个机会去真正地正念，只专注于艺术，让我们的头脑从生活中的压力或担忧中休息一下。或者它甚至可以给我们那个机会去以不同的方式思考，去重新评估可能正在发生的事情。很多人都有过这样的经历，当你做一些非常有创造力的事情时，实际上因为你更平静了，因为你专注于你正在做的绘画或跳舞，你实际上发现自己以一种不同的方式思考世界。当你完成时，你实际上会以不同的方式思考
then we're actually cathartically getting rid of our emotions we might be venting them for example if we're feeling angry or expressing those moods through our arts but there are also other times when actually it can be really helpful for us to distance ourselves from emotions in our lives If we're doing arts, it can give us a chance to be really mindful and just focus on the arts and give our brains a break from stresses or worries in our lives. Or it can even give us that chance to think differently to kind of reappraise what might be going on. Lots of people will have had the experience where you do something really creative and actually because you're calmer, because you're focused on the drawing you're doing or the dancing you're doing, you actually find yourself thinking a bit differently about the world. and by the time you finished, you actually think differently
关于你最初可能遇到的问题。所以艺术可以成为一种神奇的方式，给我们的头脑提供许多不同的方式，我们可以用来思考、重新评估或应对我们可能面临的挑战。我了解到美国的一项研究通过要求人们思考一件非常悲伤的事情来诱发人们的负面情绪
about the problem you might have had in the first place. So arts can be this amazing way of giving our brains lots of different ways that we can then contemplate or reassess or cope with challenges we might be facing. I understand that one study in the US induced negative emotions in people by asking them to think about a very sad event
或者向他们展示悲剧的照片，如葬礼场景或酷刑和苦难的经历，描述一下这个实验，它发现了什么，黛西？这是一项非常有趣的研究，它说，好吧，如果我们给人们一些拼图，或者我们告诉他们画形状和复制东西，那么这会有助于调节他们的情绪，例如让他们平静下来，或者以一种比我们实际上让他们做创造性事情更好或更差的方式来减轻他们的压力吗？
or showing them photographs of tragedies like funeral scenes or experiences of torture. and suffering, describe this experiment for me and what it found, Daisy? This is a really interesting study that said, well, if we give people kind of puzzles or we tell them to draw shapes and copy things, then will that help to regulate their emotions, to calm them down, for example, or to de-stress them in a better or worse way than if we actually let them do creative things?
他们实际上发现的是，如果人们拥有那种创造性的自由，比如他们可以自由地绘画，或者他们可以表达性地写下他们的感受，他们实际上能更好地、更快地调节他们的情绪。所以它确实突显了艺术中的创造力是当我们感到压力或担忧时，真正能支持我们的事情之一。我了解到你在你自己的女儿身上亲眼目睹了这种现象。嗯，我有年幼的孩子，正如任何年幼孩子的父母都能证明的那样，你看到孩子们真的不得不与一些大的情绪和大的经历作斗争。我从我自己的孩子身上注意到的一件事是，如果他们
And what they actually found is if people had that creative freedom, like they could draw freely or they could write expressively about what they were feeling, they actually helped to regulate their emotions much better, much faster. So it really highlighted that the creativity in the arts is one of the things that can really support us when we're feeling stressed or when we're feeling worried. I understand that you've seen something of this phenomenon firsthand when it comes to your own daughter. Well, I've got young children, and as any parents to young children will be able to attest, like you see children really having to grapple with some big emotions and big experiences. And something I've noticed with my own kids is that if ever
对某事感到担忧或焦虑，那么仅仅能够给他们一些纸和蜡笔，他们开始画出这些东西是多么令人难以置信。有时这是一种愤怒的涂鸦。其他时候，它是对平静形状的更具宣泄性的绘画。我的孩子只是蹒跚学步，所以他们真的很小，但这只是表明年幼的孩子是多么天生地被吸引以一种非常有机的方式使用艺术来支持他们的情绪。我认为当我们成为成年人时，我们可能会忘记这一点。我们可能会忘记艺术可以成为一种如此强大的方式
they're feeling worried about something or anxious about something, then just being able to hand them some paper and crayons, it's incredible how much they'll start to draw that. Sometimes it's sort of angry scribbling. Other times it's more cathartic drawing of calm shapes. And my children are only toddlers, so they're really young, but that just shows how innately young children are drawn to using the arts in a very organic way to support their emotions. And I think we can forget this as we become adults. We can forget that the arts can be such a powerful way
来支持我们的情绪。所以我总是认为孩子们是这方面的一个非常好的例子。你研究了集体歌唱对癌症患者的影响。跟我说说这项工作，黛西。
of supporting our emotions. So I always think children are such an amazing example of this for us. You've studied the effects of group singing on patients dealing with cancer. Tell me about this work, Daisy.
我研究了艺术在许多不同患者群体中可能产生的影响，在这些群体中，我们可能对疾病有医疗手段，但我们可能没有解决方案来从整体上思考那个人正在经历什么。
I've looked at the effect that the arts can have in lots of different patient groups where actually we might have a medical treatment for the illness, but we might not have a solution for thinking about holistically what that person is experiencing.
我在英国癌症医院所做的工作，我们研究了为人们设立合唱团，这是一种在社交环境中将人们聚集在一起的方式，在那里他们也许能够找到一些社会支持和陪伴，以及理解他们正在经历什么的人。但唱歌也是一种在生理上可以让他们放松的事情。我们通过研究发现，当我们唱歌时，我们降低了压力荷尔蒙的水平，
The work that I've done in cancer hospitals in the UK, we've looked at having choirs for people, which have been a way of bringing people together in a social setting where they might be able to find some social support and companionship and people who understand what they're going through. But also singing is something that physiologically can relax them. We've discovered through the studies that when we sing, we reduce our levels of stress hormones,
我们也减少了免疫系统中的炎症，这不仅与我们的身体健康有关，也与抑郁、抑郁症状等感觉有关。我们还发现，如果人们正在学习这种一起唱歌的新技能，他们可以通过合唱团体验到一种真正的自信感。他们正在进行表演。
and we also reduce inflammation in our immune system, which is linked not just to our physical health, but also to feelings like depression, depressive sympathisms. And we've also found that people can experience a real sense of confidence through the choirs if they are learning this new skill of singing together. They're putting on performances.
我们通过研究发现，参与研究的患者表示，当他们接受癌症治疗时，他们的自尊心受到了真正的打击。但这实际上是一种他们再次表演的方式。他们在身体上感到更自信，在社交上更自信，
We found through our research that patients who'd been in the studies were saying that they'd felt that their self-esteem had taken a real hit when they'd been undergoing cancer treatment. But this was actually a way they were performing again. They were feeling more confident in their bodies, more confident socially,
这正在帮助他们应对癌症的心理体验。我也在反思这样一个事实，即集体歌唱涉及在一个群体中唱歌。所以这不仅仅是音乐或歌唱。它可能正在帮助患者与他人建立联系。非常如此。我认为我们在许多不同类型的艺术体验中都看到了这一点。它们可以成为我们获得社交互动或舞蹈中的身体活动（例如）或认知刺激的载体。所以我们已经知道对我们的健康非常有益的事情。
and it was helping them to navigate the psychological experience of cancer. I'm also reflecting on the fact that group singing involves singing in a group. So it's not just the music or the singing. It's probably helping patients connect with others. Very much so. And I think we see this across lots of different kinds of arts experiences. They can be this vehicle to us getting social interaction or physical activity in dance, for example, or cognitive stimulation. So things that we already know are really good for our health.
所以艺术有机地将许多这些成分结合在一起。但艺术也确实带来了额外的东西。它们是进行更多多感官刺激、创造力以及对美学的欣赏和想象力运用的机会。我认为艺术能够将所有这些东西结合成一种体验，这一事实使它们对我们的健康如此强大。现在，当然，试图在艺术中表达自己需要一定程度的技巧和控制。谈谈参与艺术如何能给我们带来掌控感、控制感。
So the arts organically bring lots of those ingredients together. But the arts also do bring extra things as well. They're a chance for more multisensory stimulation and creativity and an appreciation of aesthetics and the use of our imagination. And I think it's the fact that the arts can combine all of those things into one experience that makes them so powerful for our health. Now, of course, trying to express yourself in art requires a certain amount. of craft and control. Talk a little bit about how engaging in the arts can give us feelings of mastery, feelings of control.
这是许多人在生活中可能觉得具有挑战性的事情，即找到一种他们能感受到那种掌控感和控制感的方式。有些人可以通过他们的工作或家庭生活获得这一点，但有很多人实际上并没有得到这一点，他们在生活的其他方面可能会感到非常无力。但许多研究现在表明，如果我们能参与艺术并建立艺术技能，即使是非常简单的事情，比如学习弹奏吉他曲目，或者学习如何做简单的手工活动，比如做一些针织、钩针编织或刺绣。这实际上可以成为建立我们能力感、我们能做某事的感觉、我们的掌控感的一种非常好的方式。这是我们幸福感的核心组成部分之一。所以确保我们正在培养这一点是非常重要的事情。
This is something that many people can find challenging in their lives, is finding a way that they can feel that sense of mastery and control. And some people can get that through their work or through their home life, but there are plenty of people who don't actually get that, who can feel really disempowered in other aspects of their lives. But lots of studies have now shown that if we can engage in the arts and build artistic skills, even really simple things like learning to play a piece on the guitar or learning how to do a simple craft activity, like do some knitting or crocheting or embroidery. This can be a really good way of actually building our sense of ability, a sense that we can do something, our sense of mastery. And this is one of the really core components of our well-being. So it's a very important thing to make sure that we're cultivating.
但它也可以帮助我们建立对自己的信念，我们对自己自我效能感或代理感的感觉。这些是非常重要的生活技能，实际上也会影响我们所有的其他健康行为。如果人们开始感到他们擅长某种创造性的事情，他们建立了那种技能，那么这可以帮助他们感到更自信，他们可以尝试生活中的不同技能。所以如此多的研究表明，像加入社区艺术团体这样简单的事情，例如，可以导致相当重大的生活决定，比如采取另一种健康行为或换工作，或决定出去寻找新朋友，承担人们以前认为自己做不到的挑战。你讲述了一个名叫谢伊的女性的故事。你能讲讲她的故事吗，黛西？
But it can also then help us to build our belief in ourselves, our feelings of our own self-efficacy or agency. And these are really important life skills that actually affect all of our other health behaviours too. If people start to feel a sense that they're good at something creative, they've built up that skill, then that can help them to feel more confident that they could try a different skill in their lives. So so many studies have shown that something as simple as joining a community arts group, for example, can lead to quite major life decisions like taking up another health behaviour or changing job or deciding to go out and find new friends, taking on challenges people haven't thought they could do before. You tell the story of a woman named Shea. Can you tell me her story, Daisy?
谢伊是一位律师，目前住在休斯顿，她向我描述说，她作为一名律师拥有非常成功的职业生涯，但并没有从那份工作中感到真正的满足。她形容她的生活是灰色的，而不是技术性的。她对此非常担心，特别是当她的母亲变得非常不健康并患上癌症时。她的母亲对她说，我真的希望你在生活中找到那种满足感。但谢伊记得她在年轻时通过歌唱体验感到非常快乐。
Shea is an attorney who currently now lives in Houston, and she is someone who described to me that she had a really successful career as an attorney, but just wasn't feeling really fulfilled from that work. She described her life as being kind of grey rather than technicaler. And she was really concerned about this, particularly as her mother became very unwell with developed cancer. And her mother was saying to her, I really want you to find that sense of fulfilment in your life. But She remembered being really happy through singing experiences when she was younger.
所以她迈出了这一大步，报名参加了伯克利学院为期一周的音乐课程，这是一种非传统的假期。她向我描述了这如何成为她生活中的一个彻底转折点。那门课程让她感到非常快乐，建立了那种掌控感，真正改变了她对自己的看法以及她能做什么，也改变了她生活的其余部分。所以在那之后，她决定她要改变她的律师工作，仍然继续，但实际上为音乐和她的生活腾出更多的空间。她开始做更多的唱作人工作，甚至进行巡演。
So she took this big leap and she signed up to a week-long music course at Berkeley College, a kind of unconventional vacation. And she described to me how this was a complete turning point in her life. that that course made her feel so happy, built that sense of mastery, really changed her whole outlook on herself and what she could do as well as the rest of her life. So after that, she decided that she was going to shift her attorney work and still carry on, but actually make much more space for music and her life. And she started doing more singer-songwriting work and even doing tours.
现在，几年后，她说她已经彻底改变了她生活中的那种幸福感。她设法利用音乐来补偿和平衡她没有从工作中得到的东西。我觉得谢伊的故事是一个如此普遍的故事。有太多人觉得他们的工作没有给他们那种完全的满足感。但实际上，并没有意识到像在业余时间发展一种艺术爱好这样简单的事情可以彻底改变他们生活中的那种平衡感，从而改变他们对幸福感的整体体验。所以鉴于所有这些研究线索，我想知道是否有证据表明艺术可以帮助
And now, like years later, she says that she's completely transformed that sense of well-being in her life. She's managed to use music to sort of, compensate and balance out the things that she wasn't getting through her work. And I feel like Shea's story is such a universal one. There are so many people who feel like their jobs are not giving them that full sense of fulfillment. But actually, don't realize that something as simple as developing an artistic hobby on the side could completely change that sense of balance in their lives and as a result, their whole experience of their well-being. So given all these strands of research, I'm wondering if there's evidence that the arts can help to
预防抑郁症，黛西？这是一个非常重要的问题，也是大约10年前开始让我着迷的问题，因为当你把我们一直在谈论的关于大脑、幸福感的益处的所有证据加在一起时，它开始让你思考，好吧，艺术是否实际上可以支持我们的整体心理韧性？所以也许我们更能免受患上抑郁症等疾病的风险。所以我是一名流行病学家，所以我的工作领域涉及使用非常大的数据集，跟踪成千上万人在他们生活数年和数十年中的队列研究。
word of depression, Daisy? This is a really important question and one that started fascinating me about 10 years ago, because when you add together all of the evidence we've been talking about for the benefits, for the brain, for our well-being, it starts to make you think, well, might the arts actually support our overall psychological resilience? So perhaps we're more protected against the risk of developing conditions like depression. So I work as an epidemiologist, so my field of work involves using very large data sets, cohort studies that track tens of thousands of people over years and decades of their lives.
实际上，我在美国和英国分析的许多这些队列研究，都观察了人们的艺术参与。它们包含了许多关于他们艺术行为的问题。所以在过去的10年里，我的团队和我实际上已经发表了数十篇论文，研究艺术参与如何与未来几十年患抑郁症的风险相关。我们发现，定期参与艺术并拥有艺术爱好的人，在未来10年内患抑郁症的风险大约降低了一半。所以你可以说，好吧，这些人只是更健康或更富有，或者在他们的生活中还有其他行为模式吗？但作为流行病学家，我们使用统计方法来基本上
And actually, a lot of these cohort studies, which I analyze in the US and in the UK, have looked at people's arts engagements. They've included lots of questions about their arts behaviours. So over the last 10 years, my team and I have been publishing dozens of papers actually looking at how arts engagement relates to the risk of developing depression over the following decades. And we found that people who engage regularly in the arts and have an artistic hobby actually have about half the risk of developing depression over the next 10 years. So you could say, well, are these people just healthier or wealthier or have other patterns of behaviours in their lives? But as epidemiologists, we use statistical methods to basically
尝试并解释所有其他可以解释这种关系的因素。所以人口统计学、行为、遗传学、人们生活的其他方面，甚至他们的过去历史。我们实际上已经看到，这种关系独立于这些因素。换句话说，艺术参与似乎充当了这种降低未来患精神疾病风险的因素。不过，因果关系的方向清楚吗？你可以想象，一个没有感到抑郁的人，一个对生活普遍感到快乐的人，可能愿意拿起画笔或尝试参加歌唱合唱团，而抑郁的人可能会远离这些活动。我们知道是艺术在降低抑郁症的风险，
try and account for all the other factors that could explain this relationship. So demographics, behaviors, genetics, other aspects of people's lives or even their past histories. And we've actually seen that this relationship is independent of these factors. In other words, arts engagement seems to act as this risk-reducing factor against the risk of developing future mental illness. Is it clear which way the arrow of causation runs, though? You could imagine that someone who is not feeling depressed, somebody who's feeling generally happy with their lives, might be willing to take up a paintbrush or try their hand at a singing choir, and somebody who is depressed might stay away from those activities. Do we know that it's the arts that is reducing the risk of depression,
还是抑郁程度较低的人可能更参与艺术？这是一个非常重要的问题，也是我们一直在努力理清的问题。当我们进行研究时，你是对的，我们确实看到了一些我们称之为双向效应的东西。它有点双向。但实际上我们一直在说，哪一个方向最强？实际上我们倾向于看到，艺术参与对未来心理健康的影响比反过来更大。实际上，我们也可以通过很多方式说，好吧，如果你目前没有抑郁症，例如，那么你的艺术参与是否会与未来患抑郁症的风险相关？
or people with lower depression who might be more engaged with the arts? That is such an important question and it's one that we've really been trying to disentangle. When we've run our studies, you're right that we have seen some what we call bidirectional effects. It kind of goes both ways. But actually we've been saying, well, which way is strongest? And actually we tend to see that actually arts engagement has more of an influence on future mental health than the other way arounds. And actually there are lots of ways that we can also say, well, if you currently don't have depression, for example, then is your arts engagement going to be related to the future risk of depression?
因此，我们知道这不仅仅是你目前的抑郁症状。基本上，通过使用许多不同的统计方法，我们实际上已经能够证明，正是艺术参与在预测未来患抑郁症的风险，即使在我们考虑了那些双向效应之后。我了解到，这项研究中的一些内容也观察了艺术可能帮助我们抵御认知能力下降的想法。向我解释这个想法，并告诉我你在这里所做的工作。
Therefore, we know that it's not simply your current depressive symptoms. And basically, through using lots of different statistical methods, we've actually been able to demonstrate that it is the arts engagement that is predicting future risk of depression, even when we've taken account of those bidirectional effects. I understand that some of this research has also looked at the idea that the arts might help us to hold off cognitive. decline. Explain this idea to me and tell me about the work you've done here.
所以当我们参与艺术时，我们实际上是在给我们的大脑进行相当有效的全脑锻炼。我们涉及了大脑中许多不同的区域，这些区域可能参与了乐谱的视觉处理，例如，或者所需的运动反应，或者记忆，或者正在被激活的情绪。我们现在通过许多研究看到的是，当人们定期参与艺术时，它实际上支持了他们的认知功能。我们在神经影像研究中可以看到这一点，这些研究表明，当人们定期参与艺术时，大脑不同区域的大小和连接性有所增加。但我们也可以随着时间的推移看到这一点。随着人们年龄的增长，那些有更规律的艺术参与模式的人实际上有更好的认知保留。
So when we engage in the arts, we're really giving our brains quite an effective whole brain workout. We're involving so many different regions of the brain that might be involved in the visual processing of sheet music, for example, or the motor response that's required, or the memory, or the emotions that are being activated. And what we've seen through a lot of studies now is that when people are regularly engaged in the arts, it actually supports their They develop increased cognitive functioning. And we can see this evident in neuroimaging studies that have shown increases in the size and connectivity between different brain regions when people engage regularly in the arts. But we can also see this over time. As people get older, those who've got more regular patterns of arts engagement actually have better preservation of their cognition.
因此，当我们参与艺术活动时，实际上是在给大脑进行一场非常有效的全脑锻炼。我们调动了大脑中许多不同的区域，例如处理乐谱的视觉区域、所需的运动反应、记忆力，或是被激活的情绪。通过大量的研究，我们现在看到，当人们经常参与艺术活动时，这实际上支持了他们的认知功能，并使其得到增强。我们可以在神经影像研究中清楚地看到这一点，这些研究表明，当人们经常参与艺术活动时，大脑不同区域的大小和连接性都会增加。随着时间的推移，我们也能观察到这一点。随着年龄的增长，那些有更规律艺术参与习惯的人，其认知能力实际上得到了更好的保持。
And in fact, they even tend to have younger brain ages. we can estimate someone's brain age based on how their brain is connecting and the patterns of connectivity across brain regions. And people who are amateurs or professionals, their brains actually are younger as they get older compared to their chronological age. So that's on average about five to seven years younger as they head into older adulthoods, their brains are. And actually we've seen that this is related as well to a delayed onset of the symptoms of dementia. Because with dementia, even if your brain is starting to accumulate,
事实上，他们的大脑年龄往往更年轻。我们可以根据大脑的连接方式以及大脑区域间的连接模式来估算一个人的大脑年龄。无论是业余爱好者还是专业人士，随着年龄增长，他们的大脑实际上比其实际年龄更年轻。平均而言，当他们步入老年时，大脑会年轻约五到七岁。事实上，我们已经观察到这与痴呆症症状的延迟出现有关。因为对于痴呆症，即使你的大脑开始积累，
some of the plaques that are typical of conditions like Alzheimer's disease, people who've got higher levels of what we call cognitive reserve, they're actually able to compensate for longer, so their brains are able to adapt and deal with it so that they don't show the outside symptoms of dementia until later on. And what we seem to be finding through lots of different studies now is that arts engagement is helping to build that cognitive reserve so that people, even if they start to develop dementia, they can manage cognitively, better for longer. And in some ways, there's an analogy here with physical health.
一些阿尔茨海默病等疾病典型的斑块，那些拥有更高水平所谓“认知储备”的人，实际上能够进行更长时间的代偿，因此他们的大脑能够适应并处理这些问题，从而直到较晚的时候才表现出痴呆症的外部症状。我们现在通过许多不同的研究发现，艺术参与有助于建立这种认知储备，即使人们开始患上痴呆症，他们也能在更长的时间内保持更好的认知能力。在某些方面，这与身体健康有类比之处。
So, you know, if you're very healthy, if you're strong and you go through a period of decline, you have longer to go before you get incapacitated because you have, you know, more muscle to start with, more cardiovascular health to start with. And you're making the same case, really, for what happens in our minds. The more we practice certain things, the more we develop a craft, a skill, a mental ability, a cognitive ability. This gives us reserves that help us, you know, save off decline for longer periods of time?
所以，你知道，如果你非常健康，如果你很强壮，即使经历了一段衰退期，由于你起初拥有更多的肌肉储备和更好的心血管健康，你在变得丧失能力之前会有更长的时间。对于我们的思维来说，其实也是同样的道理。我们练习某些事情越多，我们培养的技艺、技能、心理能力和认知能力就越多。这给了我们储备，帮助我们延缓衰退的时间，不是吗？
That's essentially right as a metaphor. But there used to be a kind of craze about, well, could we do this through brain training apps, like games you would do on your phone that would build that cognitive function? But actually when the big studies of this came out, the results weren't that impressive because there was a kind of realization that those games are only practicing one cognitive function at a time. But this is where arts really has the upper hands, because when you're engaging in the arts, you've got so many different cognitive processes. that are being activated by that engagement,
作为一个比喻，这基本上是正确的。但过去曾有一种狂热，认为我们是否可以通过大脑训练应用程序来实现这一点，比如你在手机上玩的游戏，可以增强认知功能？但实际上，当相关的大型研究结果出来时，效果并不令人印象深刻，因为人们意识到这些游戏一次只练习一种认知功能。而这正是艺术的优势所在，因为当你参与艺术活动时，你有许多不同的认知过程被这种参与所激活，
that whole brain workout that I spoke about. And that's why I think the arts is such an exciting opportunity for supporting our brains as we get older. Across many years of research, scientists like Daisy have been building evidence to prove that engagement with the arts can make a real difference. When we come back, how to bring the arts into our daily lives and reap all the riches they have to offer.
也就是我所说的全脑锻炼。这就是为什么我认为艺术对于我们在年老时支持大脑健康是一个如此令人兴奋的机会。经过多年的研究，像黛西这样的科学家一直在积累证据，证明参与艺术活动可以带来真正的改变。稍后回来，我们将探讨如何将艺术融入日常生活，并收获它所能提供的所有财富。
Also, in our companion story to this episode, available exclusively to subscribers to Hidden Brain Plus, we dive deeper into the role of the arts in medicine. If you're a subscriber, that episode is available right now. It's titled The Healing Arts. If you're not yet a subscriber, please go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, please go to apple.com slash hidden brain. You can get a free seven-day trial in both places,
此外，在本集节目的配套故事中（仅供 Hidden Brain Plus 订阅者专享），我们深入探讨了艺术在医学中的作用。如果您是订阅者，该集节目现在即可收听，标题为《治愈艺术》。如果您还不是订阅者，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果您使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com/hiddenbrain。您可以在这两个地方获得七天的免费试用，
and you'll instantly have access to all our subscriber-only content. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org or Apple.co slash hidden brain. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Has this conversation stirred thoughts of encounters you've had with the arts? If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with a hidden brain audience or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty.
您将立即获得我们所有订阅者专享内容的访问权限。再次重申，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.co/hiddenbrain。您正在收听的是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这段对话是否勾起了您与艺术接触的回忆？如果您有一个愿意与《Hidden Brain》听众分享的个人故事，或者对本集节目有任何问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。
Then email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, arts. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Daisy Fancourt is a psychobiologist at University College London. She is the author of ArtCure, the science of how the arts save lives. Daisy, you say that a first step in accessing the benefits of the arts is to figure out how to add some aspect of the arts to our lives every single day.
然后将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请注明“arts”。再次重申，地址是 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。黛西·范考特是伦敦大学学院的心理生物学家。她是《艺术治愈：艺术如何拯救生命的科学》一书的作者。黛西，你说获取艺术益处的第一步是想办法每天在生活中加入艺术的某些方面。
How do you advise people to do this? I think it's great to think about this in the same way we think about our diet or our exercise. We're used to target 10,000 steps a day or eat five fruit and vegetables a day or whatever. And I think having a simple rule like that is a really great way of starting. Now, for some people, that might be 10 or 15 or 20 minutes
你建议人们如何做到这一点？我认为像对待饮食或锻炼一样对待这件事是非常好的。我们习惯于设定每天一万步的目标，或者每天吃五种水果和蔬菜等等。我认为有一个像这样简单的规则是一个非常好的开始方式。现在，对有些人来说，这可能是10、15或20分钟，
that you're able to put aside. And there can be really easy ways of doing this, even sort of simple swaps that you can have in your life. So, for example, one that I do is I have what I call a creative commute. So I can't, I live too far away to cycle or run to work. But when I'm on my train each day, I'm not allowed to scroll my phone. Instead, I use that time to sit and listen to music or to read my book. And that's a really easy way of making sure I get those minutes every single day.
你可以腾出这些时间。做到这一点的方法可以非常简单，甚至是你生活中一些简单的交换。例如，我做的一件事是我称之为“创意通勤”。我住得太远，无法骑车或跑步上班。但每天在火车上时，我不允许刷手机。相反，我利用这段时间坐下来听音乐或看书。这是确保我每天都能获得这些时间的非常简单的方法。
You see that it's important to focus on consistency. So rather than trying to get four hours and one day and nothing for the rest of the week, it's more helpful to get 20 minutes every day? If we're engaging regularly, it's much more likely to become a habit that sticks. So you're much more likely to find that you don't just cancel that one day and then realize it's been a couple of weeks since you did everything. But it also means you can be getting those benefits day-to-day. And lots of the immediate benefits people get from arts engagements
你认为专注于持续性很重要。所以比起试图在一天内完成四个小时，而其余时间什么都不做，每天20分钟更有帮助吗？如果我们定期参与，它就更有可能成为一种坚持下去的习惯。这样你就不太可能只取消那一天，然后意识到已经好几周没做任何事了。这也意味着你可以每天获得这些益处。人们从艺术参与中获得的许多直接益处，
for things like stress and for mood. And those are things that we can all benefit from having the little pick-me-ups. embedded in our day-to-day lives. And we also see that a lot of the evidence about the long-term benefits is really focused on sustainability of engagement. So having something that you do as a habit for months or years of your lives, if you really want to be supporting things like brain health, for example, as you get older, or the reduced risk of developing various mental and physical health conditions.
比如缓解压力和改善情绪。这些都是我们所有人都能从中受益的日常小确幸。我们还看到，关于长期益处的许多证据确实集中在参与的可持续性上。因此，如果你真的想支持大脑健康，或者降低患各种身心健康疾病的风险，那么将某件事作为习惯坚持数月或数年是非常有意义的。
So I think it's really great to find that daily dose that's achievable for you. You know, some people struggle to start an exercise routine and they find it helpful to join an exercise class or maybe to get a trainer. And in some ways, perhaps the same is true when it comes to the arts. I think it is true because some people are concerned that they're not artistic or creative enough or they're not good at something. They haven't got the right skills. So it can be really effective to start a hobby, an arts hobby, by joining a local group or by having a couple of lessons, a bit of instruction to get you. or even using things like YouTube, so you've got some videos or an online community for some support to get you going. And actually for things that involve a certain level of skill to be able to really get the most of them,
所以我认为找到适合你的每日剂量是非常棒的。你知道，有些人很难开始锻炼计划，他们觉得参加健身课程或找个教练很有帮助。在某些方面，艺术也是如此。我认为确实如此，因为有些人担心自己不够艺术或不够有创造力，或者不擅长某事。他们没有合适的技能。所以，通过加入当地团体或上几节课、获得一点指导来开始一种艺术爱好，是非常有效的。甚至可以使用 YouTube 等工具，通过视频或在线社区获得支持来帮助你入门。事实上，对于那些需要一定技能水平才能真正从中获益的事情，
so things like craft activities or learning musical instruments, literature now suggests that if you can do something for 50 hours, then actually you tend to have the level of skill that mean you can really fly with it on your own and really start to enjoy it and get into the flow of it. So that can be good for people to recognize that it might take a few weeks, to feel like they're really comfortable with an artistic hobby. So to give themselves the time to have those experiences and build that level of comfort.
比如手工活动或学习乐器，现在的文献表明，如果你能坚持做某事50个小时，那么你往往就具备了能够独立发挥并真正开始享受它、进入心流状态的技能水平。所以让人们认识到可能需要几周时间才能感到对一种艺术爱好真正舒适，这对他们是有好处的。让他们给自己时间去体验并建立那种舒适感。
Intuitively, it seems to me that if you can do an arts activity with someone whom you like, a friend, it's a little bit like starting a workout routine with a friend. You're more likely to stick to it. Definitely. And actually, there are some great ways you can do this in your lives. So in the UK, actually, we found there are lots of venues like pubs or bars that are now doing crafts evenings
直觉上，我觉得如果你能和喜欢的人（比如朋友）一起进行艺术活动，这有点像和朋友一起开始锻炼计划。你更有可能坚持下去。当然。事实上，你们在生活中有很多很棒的方法可以做到这一点。在英国，我们发现有很多像酒吧或餐馆这样的场所现在都在举办手工之夜，
so you can go alone, you can socialise with friends, but you can have that artistic focus. Or you can meet up with friends at a gallery or an exhibition as a way of having something to look at as well as that time to talk to each other. Something that I've heard of some couples doing now is instead of going for a date-night dinner, actually going to watch a show or to go to a gig so that they're actually embedding those creative experiences
所以你可以独自前往，可以与朋友社交，但同时拥有艺术焦点。或者你可以和朋友在画廊或展览馆见面，这既是一种可以欣赏的东西，也是彼此交谈的时间。我听说现在有些情侣不再去吃约会晚餐，而是去看演出或去听音乐会，这样他们就把那些创造性的体验，
with the social experiences that they've already made the time for in their diaries. I want to go back to something that you mentioned a second earlier because I think this is a real barrier for many people. You know, people say I'm not musical or I can't draw to save my life. Talk about this barrier, the sense of shame that we have about our own artistic abilities, especially compared to what we might see on social media of other people posting their accomplishments. How this is in some ways a barrier to us jumping into the water and trying something ourselves? I think it's really a sign about how we as societies, sort of taken arts engagement and actually commodified it. We've sort of made it this object,
与他们已经在日程表中预留出的社交体验结合在了一起。我想回到你刚才提到的一个点，因为我认为这对许多人来说是一个真正的障碍。你知道，人们会说“我不懂音乐”或者“我这辈子都画不好画”。谈谈这个障碍，谈谈我们对自己艺术能力的羞耻感，尤其是与我们在社交媒体上看到的其他人展示的成就相比时。这在某种程度上是如何成为我们跳入水中尝试新事物的障碍的？我认为这确实反映了我们作为一个社会，是如何将艺术参与商品化的。我们把它变成了一种对象，
this thing that you're supposed to be good at, or you have to feel like you've had particular training to be allowed to do it. But just look back at young children, because when you look at children, all children sing, they dance, they make up stories, they act things out, they constantly draw or craft. They're not worried about where they're good at it. They're really enjoying that experience. And all kids have got that innate creativity. So I think it's really helpful to draw on children as inspiration and remind ourselves that a lot of the health benefits of the arts actually come from doing it,
一种你必须擅长的东西，或者你必须觉得受过特殊训练才被允许去做的事情。但只要看看年幼的孩子，因为当你观察孩子时，所有的孩子都会唱歌、跳舞、编故事、表演、不断地画画或做手工。他们并不担心自己是否擅长。他们只是在享受那种体验。所有的孩子都拥有那种天生的创造力。所以我认为借鉴孩子作为灵感是非常有帮助的，提醒我们艺术的许多健康益处实际上来自于参与本身。
not necessarily being good at it. You say that just as we might plan our meals out, you know, that on some days we're going to eat in and some days we're going to go to a restaurant, we can do the same thing when it comes to the arts, that we can actually plan our artistic calendars? I think that's a really great way of doing things. So that might be a case of seeing if there are some exhibitions
并不一定非要擅长它。你说得对，就像我们可能会规划饮食一样，你知道，有些日子我们在家吃，有些日子去餐馆吃，我们在艺术方面也可以这样做，我们实际上可以规划我们的艺术日程？我认为这是一种非常棒的做法。所以这可能就是看看是否有展览
or a festival coming up or there are films that you really want to see or that there are certain gigs or things you need to book tickets for. It's really great to put those things in the diary because as well as having the day-to-day daily dose of arts engagement that you might try and embed in your life,
或者即将举办的节日，或者有你非常想看的电影，或者有某些演出或你需要预订门票的活动。把这些事情记在日记里真的很棒，因为除了你可能试图融入生活中的日常艺术参与之外，
having things like that can bring really exciting novelty. They can give you different experiences that might give you feelings of awe or excitements. And they're also a really good way of making sure that we're just building those additional routines to increase that overall pattern of engagement that we get with the arts. You said something important a second ago, which is that it's one thing to consume arts, going to a festival or going to an exhibition, watching a movie. It's another thing to be
拥有这样的活动可以带来非常令人兴奋的新鲜感。它们可以给你带来不同的体验，可能会让你感到敬畏或兴奋。它们也是确保我们建立额外常规以增加我们从艺术中获得的整体参与模式的好方法。你刚才说了一件重要的事情，那就是消费艺术，比如去参加节日、展览或看电影是一回事。而成为
producing art. Talk about the difference. Is there any evidence or research about the benefits of doing one or the other? Well, if we think back about what ingredients we're getting when we're engaging with the arts, if we're watching something, we're being exposed to lots of different stimuli. But if we're doing it ourselves, we're getting further types of stimuli, often tactile stimuli, for example, which people can find very therapeutic. But also if we're building our skills, that relates to those experiences of mastery that we've spoken about or a feeling of self-esteem or accomplishments that we can get through the arts as well. So a bit like the same way we try and have a variety of plants and vegetables in our diet, it can be really important to have a
艺术的创作者则是另一回事。谈谈其中的区别。有没有关于做其中任何一种的好处的证据或研究？嗯，如果我们回想一下我们在参与艺术时获得了什么成分，如果我们是在观看，我们接触到了许多不同的刺激。但如果我们自己动手，我们会获得更多类型的刺激，例如通常是触觉刺激，人们会觉得这非常有疗愈作用。而且，如果我们正在培养技能，这与我们谈到的那些精通体验，或者通过艺术获得的自尊感或成就感有关。所以，就像我们试图在饮食中摄入各种植物和蔬菜一样，拥有
variety of arts experiences because they're all exposing us to different kinds of ingredients that have health benefits. And for some health conditions, it doesn't really matter whether you are receptively watching something versus actively participating. So for a lot of mental health outcomes, we actually see that both kinds of engagements have benefits, just in slightly different ways for us. But there are other experiences, other outcomes. So things like outcomes relating to mobility or to pain, for example, we're actually having that active ingredient of participating. is giving us additional sensory engagement and additional mechanisms that can actually support those health outcomes. You recommend regularly changing up the kinds of arts that we engage in.
各种各样的艺术体验非常重要，因为它们都在让我们接触到具有健康益处的不同成分。对于某些健康状况，你是在被动观看还是主动参与其实并不重要。因此，对于许多心理健康结果，我们实际上看到这两种参与方式都有好处，只是对我们产生影响的方式略有不同。但还有其他体验和结果。例如，与行动能力或疼痛相关的结果，我们实际上是在通过参与这种积极的成分，获得额外的感官参与和额外的机制，从而真正支持这些健康结果。你建议定期更换我们参与的艺术类型。
I'm wondering why this is, Daisy. If you love something, why not just stick to it? If you love something, then absolutely you can stick to it to a certain degree. But sometimes what people find is what we call the hedonic treadmill. If they're doing something that they enjoy, they can sometimes start to adapt to it. and it doesn't necessarily continue to bring exactly the same kinds of well-being benefits. So people actually will often organically shift things up. So, for example, if you're someone that's really into crafts and you've been really enjoying doing a certain kind of knitting, for example,
我很好奇为什么会这样，黛西。如果你喜欢某样东西，为什么不坚持下去呢？如果你喜欢某样东西，那么在一定程度上你当然可以坚持下去。但有时人们会发现所谓的“享乐适应”。如果他们正在做自己喜欢的事情，有时他们会开始适应它，它不一定会继续带来完全相同类型的幸福感。所以人们实际上经常会自然地做出改变。例如，如果你是一个非常喜欢手工艺的人，并且一直很享受某种编织，例如，
you actually might find that you're setting yourself different kinds of challenges or different patterns that you're trying to learn. But sometimes people can still find that it's good to mix things up and bring in a completely different type of art's hobby. because that can be a great way of exposing their brains to novelty, to sparking their imagination, and to perhaps making sure that whatever behavioral routines they've got in their lives keep that freshness and excitement to them. I think many of us do engage with music or the arts, but we often do it as we're doing something else. So you're racing home from work, maybe you're on a train, you're playing some music, but you're also reading your email. It's one thing to listen to a beautiful piece of music with one ear and quite a very important.
你实际上可能会发现自己正在设定不同类型的挑战或试图学习不同的图案。但有时人们仍然会发现，混合一下并引入一种完全不同类型的艺术爱好是件好事，因为这可能是让大脑接触新鲜事物、激发想象力，并确保他们生活中的任何行为习惯保持新鲜感和兴奋感的好方法。我认为我们许多人确实会接触音乐或艺术，但我们经常在做其他事情的同时进行。所以你从工作中匆忙赶回家，也许你在火车上，你在播放一些音乐，但你同时也在阅读电子邮件。用一只耳朵听一首优美的音乐是一回事，而
another to immerse ourselves completely in it. You talked a second ago about how when you are commuting home from work, you actually are devoting your full attention to the art that you're consuming. Talk about this, the importance of actually sitting and savoring and focusing on the art, not just doing it with one ear or one eye. Yes. When we listen to music, for example, quite in the background, it can still be having some benefits for us, like reducing stress response, for example. But if it's not getting our full attention, we're not going to be getting the maximum impact from it. So I think it's really important that we are consciously aware about how much we are passively engaging in the arts versus giving it that full attention. Because when we give it
完全沉浸在其中则是另一回事。你刚才谈到当你下班回家时，你实际上是在全神贯注于你所消费的艺术。谈谈这一点，即坐下来细细品味并专注于艺术的重要性，而不是仅仅用一只耳朵或一只眼睛去应付。是的。例如，当我们把音乐当作背景音乐听时，它仍然可以给我们带来一些好处，比如减轻压力反应。但如果它没有得到我们的全神贯注，我们就无法从中获得最大的影响。所以我认为，我们有意识地意识到我们是在被动地参与艺术，还是在全神贯注地参与，这一点非常重要。因为当我们给予它
full attention, all of our emotional responses are heightened, our stress responses are heightened as well. And also we've got a chance to really get into the flow of what we're doing. And if we can really get into that flow state, that feeling of complete absorption, where we're, forgetting everything else in our lives, it has profound benefits for our mental health. And it also has profound benefits for our brain health. It actually leads to synchronization between particular brain regions and enhances our overall attention as well. So I think it's really great that we can ensure that we are giving our time and space rather than just always relegating it to background passive consumption. I'm thinking, Daisy, about how sometimes when I'm
全神贯注时，我们所有的情绪反应都会增强，我们的压力反应也会增强。而且我们也有机会真正进入我们正在做的事情的节奏中。如果我们真的能进入那种心流状态，那种完全沉浸的感觉，让我们忘记生活中其他一切，这对我们的心理健康有深远的好处。它对我们的大脑健康也有深远的好处。它实际上会导致特定大脑区域之间的同步，并增强我们的整体注意力。所以我认为，确保我们给予它时间和空间，而不是总是把它降级为背景下的被动消费，是非常棒的。我在想，黛西，关于有时当我
eating, you know, some dessert, if I actually take my time with it and linger over it and savour it, The dessert tastes two or three times as good as a dessert that I'm rushing through. And the same thing in some ways is true for art. Absolutely. We get a much deeper appreciation and enjoyment from it. Essentially, all of our senses are heightened when we're giving ourselves that full attention on what we're doing. And we see things like increased dopamine release or increased feelings of happiness if we're really focusing on the art. A reminder, do you have a personal story about the effects of the arts in your life or the life of a family member?
吃甜点时，你知道，如果我真的花时间去品味它，慢慢享受它，甜点的味道会比我匆忙吃掉的好两三倍。在某种程度上，艺术也是如此。绝对是这样。当我们全神贯注于我们正在做的事情时，我们会从中获得更深刻的欣赏和享受。本质上，当我们全神贯注于我们正在做的事情时，我们所有的感官都会变得敏锐。如果我们真的专注于艺术，我们会看到多巴胺分泌增加或幸福感增加等现象。提醒一下，你是否有关于艺术对你的生活或家庭成员的生活产生影响的个人故事？
If you have a story you are willing to share with a hidden brain audience or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email it to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org using the subject line, arts. Again, that's Feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Daisy, I understand that you have come up with a number of ways to incorporate the arts into your own daily life. paint a picture for me of what you've done? One of the things that I've done in my life is I've tried to work out across the day, when am I most likely to be able to benefit from the arts?
如果你有一个愿意与“隐藏的大脑”听众分享的故事，或者对本集有任何问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。请发送电子邮件至 Feedback@hiddenbrain.org，主题行请写上“arts”。再说一遍，是 Feedback@hiddenbrain.org。黛西，我了解到你已经想出了许多将艺术融入自己日常生活的方法。能为我描绘一下你所做的事情吗？我在生活中所做的一件事是，我试图计算出在一天中，我最有可能从艺术中受益的时间是什么时候？
So I've often found that if I swap my alarm on my phone to a really calming piece of music in the mornings, that really subtle shift can completely change my mood when I first get up and how I'm starting my day. I've also found some of the times like in the afternoon and sometimes I have a bit of an energy dip, where I know that actually putting on some music can be a really great way of, freshening up my mood or it can be a great chance to actually take a little bit of a break from work and just help me to shake up that slump in the afternoon. I'm somebody that really loves to be sociable in the evenings. So I've really enjoyed being able to find ways of combining my socialising with also seeing friends as well. That's felt like a really nice way of not having to
所以我经常发现，如果我把手机闹钟换成早上播放一段非常平静的音乐，那种微妙的转变可以完全改变我起床时的心情以及我开始一天的方式。我还发现，在下午等某些时候，有时我会感到精力下降，我知道实际上播放一些音乐可以成为提振心情的好方法，或者这可能是一个从工作中休息一下的好机会，只是帮助我摆脱下午的低迷。我是一个在晚上非常喜欢社交的人。所以我真的很享受能够找到将社交与见朋友结合起来的方法。这感觉真是一种很好的方式，不必
find more time, but being able to maximize the time that I do have to have those more meaningful experiences with people. And I've also deliberately across my week, a couple of sessions in where I do things like a book club or I'll go to go and try a new class or a taster session of something because I find that that's another great way of keeping my engagement really novel and fresh. I'm wondering when you socialize with friends, you sometimes say that you skip having drinks or dinners and try and swap in an arts activity instead. Can you paint me a picture of a time when you did this with some friends, Daisy?
寻找更多的时间，而是能够最大限度地利用我拥有的时间与人们进行更有意义的体验。而且我也在每周刻意安排了几次会议，比如读书俱乐部，或者我会去尝试一个新的课程或某种体验课，因为我发现这是保持我的参与感非常新颖和新鲜的另一种好方法。我很好奇，当你和朋友社交时，你有时说你会跳过喝酒或晚餐，而是尝试换成艺术活动。黛西，你能为我描绘一下你和朋友们这样做的一次经历吗？
I found recently that I've been meeting some friends at galleries or exhibitions that have been on. And it's a really great way to be catching up, but whilst you're looking around and able to think about and talk about the paintings as well. I also think it can be a really nice way. If you've got things you want to talk about with friends that are a little bit harder or more emotionally intense, to actually do something that's not just sitting opposite people at a dining table, for example, but actually somewhere where you've got a little bit of space and walking around galleries or listening to music, might be being performed in kind of public events, it can be a great way of actually giving yourself a little bit more time and focus
我最近发现我一直在画廊或正在举办的展览中见一些朋友。这是一种很好的叙旧方式，同时你可以在四处观看时思考并谈论这些画作。我也认为这可能是一种很好的方式。如果你有想和朋友谈论的事情，而这些事情稍微困难或情绪更强烈一些，那么做一些不仅仅是坐在餐桌对面面对面交谈的事情，例如，去一个你有更多空间的地方，比如在画廊里走动，或者听听可能在公共活动中表演的音乐，这可能是让你自己有更多时间和专注力去
to actually have some more difficult conversations too. I was talking to a friend recently who told me that, you know, before she had kids, you know, she and her husband would go ballroom dancing multiple times a week. And of course, I'm reflecting now as I'm hearing you speak that in some ways, that has so many different components of what you just talked about. You're listening to the music, you're dancing, you're social, you're being with someone. All of these things in some ways have profound benefits for us.
进行一些更困难对话的好方法。我最近和一个朋友聊天，她告诉我，你知道，在她有孩子之前，她和她丈夫每周会去跳好几次交谊舞。当然，我现在听你说话时在反思，在某种程度上，这包含了你刚才谈到的许多不同组成部分。你在听音乐，你在跳舞，你在社交，你在和某人在一起。所有这些事情在某种程度上对我们都有深远的好处。
They do, and they're often much more memorable as events to do together than simply going out for a meal. And actually, we do know from a social bonding perspective that if we do arts with people, so if we sing or we dance with people, we actually become emotionally closer with them faster than if we just talk or if we exercise with them. So it's a really lovely thing to do as well if people are forming new relationships or new friendships because it can be an amazing icebreaker and a way of helping to facilitate the development of deeper connection.
确实如此，而且作为一起参加的活动，它们通常比单纯出去吃饭更令人难忘。事实上，从社会联系的角度来看，我们确实知道，如果我们和人们一起进行艺术活动，比如我们一起唱歌或跳舞，我们实际上比仅仅交谈或一起锻炼的人更快地在情感上变得亲近。所以，如果人们正在建立新的关系或新的友谊，这也是一件非常可爱的事情，因为它可以成为一个了不起的破冰船，也是一种帮助促进建立更深层联系的方式。
Daisy Fancourt is a psychobiologist at University College London. She is the author of ArtCure, the science of how the arts save lives. Daisy, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's a pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media, Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul,
黛西·范考特是伦敦大学学院的心理生物学家。她是《艺术疗法：艺术如何拯救生命的科学》一书的作者。黛西，非常感谢你今天参加“隐藏的大脑”。这是我的荣幸。“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑媒体”制作，我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、
Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you like this episode, please think of a friend who might like it as well and share this episode with them. If they're new to Hidden Brain, they may also discover other episodes that are of interest. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
克里斯汀·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行编辑。如果你喜欢这一集，请想一想可能也会喜欢它的朋友，并与他们分享这一集。如果他们是“隐藏的大脑”的新听众，他们可能还会发现其他感兴趣的剧集。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。